artistes nationaux et internationaux se
retrouve à andrésy depuis 22 ans
il célèbre la nature à travers leurs
oeuvres originales
chaque année nous essayons d'amener de
nouveaux artistes de nouvelles visions
de nouvelles perspectives
mais en même temps on est toujours dans
cette continuité de célébrer ce rapport
à la nature la maison du moussel se voir
ollier au sophora japonais voisins à eux
deux ils forment qu'une seule et même
oeuvre dans laquelle s'expriment les
souvenirs des habitants
les arbres engrange la mémoire du monde
il a gardé dans sa mémoire tous les
souvenirs de larmes de joie et de larmes
de chagrin des habitants d'andrésy donc
nous sommes allés enquêter dans les rues
un peu au hasard en eau d'andrésy en bas
d'andrésy une installation esthétique
mais aussi sonore à l'extérieur et à
l'intérieur de la maison
j'en crée ses perles avec ces mots
d'ordre et zia je trouve c'est vraiment
plein d'émotions moi j'étais vraiment
scotché
je reconnais pas par cette heure plus
loin les sculptures d'une artiste suisse
laisse le soleil les mettre en mouvement
et j'essaie de transmettre en plus de la
nature aussi un certain optimisme parce
que les couleurs pures c'est quand même
ça donne la force dynamique un optimisme
transmis au maire d'andrésy qui
inaugurait sa dernière édition
il espère que son successeur fera
perdurer cette poésie encore longtemps